australian journalist chung lei has gone
on trial in this court in beijing
she's charged with illegally supplying
state secrets overseas
australian officials tried to get access
to the court on thursday morning but
were denied on grounds of national
security
this is deeply
concerning unsatisfactory and
regrettable
we can have no confidence in the
validity of a process
which is conducted in secret
my name is chung lei chung worked as a
television presenter for state
broadcaster cgtn before being detained
in august 2020 she was formally arrested
a year ago
the australian government says it has no
information regarding the allegations
made against her and has expressed
concern for her welfare and detention
china's foreign ministry has dismissed
the complaints
chinese judicial authorities are
handling the case in accordance with the
law and fully guarantee all the rights
of the person involved
chong was born in china and raised in
australia her two young children are
being cared for by relatives there
she hasn't been able to speak to any of
them since her arrest
rowan kalik a former correspondent in
china and friend of trunks says it's
unlikely she'll get a fair trial
the process might be due process
in terms of the chinese system but not
in terms of
most of how the rest of the world
runs its courts so i fear that
lei herself
accept insofar as she can engage from
the thrust of the interrogation to which
she's been subject
may well not know the detail of what
she's said to have done chong lei's
trial comes at a time of tense relations
between china and australia canberra has
been a vocal critic of beijing's
handling of the pandemic and its human
rights record this has resulted in
unofficial trade blocs on australian
imports and today there are no
journalists left working in china for
australian media companies
another australian writer young hong
joon is being detained in china on
spying charges and was tried in may
there's yet to be a verdict in his case
chong lei could be sentenced to life in
jail if she's convicted in china 99 of
defendants in criminal cases are found
guilty
katrina you al jazeera beijing